hey everyone how are you are you excited
about this episode
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the arts science and tools of
machine learning i am priyanka vergaria
and in this episode i'm going to show
you a tool that enables you to
automatically translate your video and
audio content to text in real time world
has become rather small with technology
we are all customers of services that
are made in another part of the world so
we've experienced situations where the
audio or video is in a language that we
don't speak and as a developer of such
global apps we clearly need to overcome
the language barrier and it's not as
simple as it seems but
what's so complicated about it it's the
data and the files because they are not
in the form of text we have to first
convert original data into text by using
speech to text to get a transcription
then we need to feed those
transcriptions into the translation api
to get the translated text
these are a lot of steps which cause a
lot of friction and add latency along
the way and it is much harder to get a
good quality translation because you
might lose context while splitting
sentences
so you eventually make a trade-off
between quality speed and ease of
deployment
that's where media translation api comes
in it simplifies this process by
abstracting away the transcription and
translation behind a single api call
allowing you to get real-time
translation from video and audio data
with high translation accuracy
there are a large number of use cases
for this you can enable real-time
engagement for users by streaming
translations from a microphone or
pre-recorded audio file you can power an
interactive experience on your platform
with video chat with translated captions
or add subtitles to your videos real
time as they are played
now let's see how it works
i'm going to say a few things here and
we will see how media translation api
translates the microphone input into
text
new delhi is the capital of india
washington dc is the capital of united
states
here we see that the api is trying to
understand the input from the microphone
and giving us the partial and the final
translation in real time
now how did i set this up let me show
you
in our project we enable media
translation api and get the service
account and key for authentication
get the python code sample from github
and in the media translation folder we
see the files translate from file and
translate from mic first we create a
python virtual environment and install
our dependencies from requirements.txt
now if we examine our translate from mic
file we see that we are creating a
client for the media translation api
service this client includes the audio
encoding the language we will speak in
to the microphone and the language we
want our translations to be in then with
that client we stream the audio from our
microphone up to the cloud and start
listening to the responses from the
service and as we listen we are printing
those responses as an output this is
also where you would incorporate this
output into your application
now while we are here let's change our
source language to hindi and target
language to english and try this again
namaste
and it rightly says hi how are you today
weather is very nice today we should go
out for a walk
decent right
in this episode we learned how media
translation api delivers high quality
real-time speech translation to our
applications directly from our
microphone you can even provide an input
audio file and achieve a similar output
there's a sample in the same folder try
it out yourself and let me know how it
goes in the comments below
like or subscribe
you